the u.s the uk and australia now all
warning that there's a high risk of a
terrorist attack at kabul airport and
they've told their citizens to stay away
from the area since afghanistan fell to
the taliban thousands of both foreign
nationals and afghans alike have been
desperately trying to flee
the area around the airport these
pictures into us and resemble something
of as you can call it disaster zone
certainly chaotic messy crammed with
people sitting there emits countless
bags and suitcases and rubbish strewn
all over the place
after the taliban rejected claims it was
going to stop afghans with international
visas from leaving the country that gave
some people some hope there of maybe
getting out even at this last minute
these last few days actually senior
correspondents in that conflict-weary
nation reports back for us next about
what life is like at the moment under
the new regime
as we were landing we expected the
situation to be
desperate horrendous even and we
certainly weren't disappointed it isn't
quite the pandemonium we saw in the
early days of this evacuation so the
mobs and the hordes crashing each other
in a bid to get to these aircraft and to
flee the taliban to flee afghanistan
things are
much more ordered now nevertheless it is
still very much desperate as we uh
descended down from the aircraft we were
greeted with with an airfield that is
littered with the shell casings bullet
casings as well as
empty flashbang grenades tear gas
canisters that have
also been used sleepers shoes clothes
children's clothes littered all over the
place one of the most striking things
was uh also for the barbed wire it is it
is everywhere i haven't seen barbed wire
layered as high as it was there it is
veritable walls of barbed wire to keep
people away from the airfield as we were
driving out of the airfield we had made
it two meters uh when we saw people
trying to rush the main gate
and the taliban fighter wildly firing
warning shots even behind his back it
was a
miracle that no one was hurt
there were thousands of people literally
thousands of people many of them young
many of them evidently trying to use the
opportunity to get out of afghanistan
but among them elder people people with
families children uh women but we're
carrying you know babies
desperate to get them out of the country
uh so so the taliban is is being
relentless very harsh
in keeping people away
as we drove further
away from the airfield though it
it must be said that things were much
more ordered shops were
open businesses were open people were
walking around with with groceries with
with food with uh necessities going
about their lives work things were much
less desperate there was traffic but it
wasn't as it was in the early days sort
of one way towards the airport but
nevertheless things are very much
chaotic here i think uh people are still
getting used to the taliban which
barely a few months ago was you know the
fringes of the country and now in charge
of the capital
russia has also been evacuating people
from kabul via the chaos stricken
international airport four russian air
force planes have been taking part in
the rescue operation taking 500 out so
far including citizens of russia belarus
ukraine and afghanistan's former soviet
neighbor tajikistan
[Music]
we hadn't expected the evacuation to go
this well it's been very good for others
it's usually taken five or six days to
evacuate we were told yesterday and
today we're already on the plane
[Music]
i want to thank russia's president and
defense minister for taking us out of
the dangerous place and bringing us to
tajikistan they fed us too many thanks
to them
[Music]
i'm happy that we're going home and our
children can be ready for school i want
to thank russia for helping us in this
tense situation because it's very
difficult now to get to the airport
[Music]
you